- So, obviously, episode 14
was very much the clouds.
It was kind of a hype video.
DRock, can you believe this today?
DRock, you crushed that.
Today was, look, I mean,
this is the day in the life
of an entrepreneur.
Sometimes you get to fly around
and run into LinkedIn,
and see billionaire sports
owners like Steve Ross,
and it's one of those days.
And other days you're just
sitting in the office all day
on a President's Day weekend
when everybody else is off.
And you're grinding through meeting,
after meeting, after meeting,
after meeting, after meeting.
You have to just bet on
your fucking core strength.
That is the game.
I'm even stopping myself.
I was just about to give
you advice of don't listen
to Paul Graham or me,
but the truth is maybe
that is how you dominate.
I wish I could take
more from other people.
You see where I'm going?
The number one thing that you can do
at this point in your life,
whether it's this app or
fucking this is where you're gonna win,
is you just need to decide
what's the one thing
that you're better at than anything else
that you're better at,
and you need to become the
extreme version of that.
That I believe more than anything.
Your creative game is your creative game.
It's like the talent you were born with,
and the practice you've
deployed against it.
But 360 yourself.
Among like EQ,
HR, like building the equity
because you know Karen loves Kanye,
and then making a Kanye joke when
Diageo's giving tough feedback,
and it's a tough moment.
That's the fucking magic.
In a world where I know
how creatives are judged
everywhere else,
I'm not waiting for your big thing.
I'm trying to see if you got
all those other little things,
because they lead to
consistent big things.
- Yeah, definitely. I
appreciate you saying that.
You're right. A lot of
people just don't say that.
It's kind of like when you
tell the people you care
you actually care about them
because people don't hear it enough.
Sometimes you have to do that.
- [Gary] That's how this thing scales.
That's why we have what we have.
- Thank you.
- Because it's not something
that's written on the wall.
- Yeah, I know.
- It's religion over tactic.
- Yep.
- Got it?
- And it really does
manifest itself in the work.
- [DRock] It's a very interesting day.
- It's a very interesting, you know what?
It's a very interesting day.
I'm in a very kind of like deep,
I'm in a funny mood.
I'm in a deep-slash-competitive mood.
I'm pissed about that fan.
- [DRock] What happened?
- A fan just thinks that
all I talk about now is
that I can outwork them,
and I don't bring them value anymore.
And that I'm not doing anything tangible
like the "early" version of me.
Yet, literally, his next
post was a carbon copy
of the way I promote and do a tactical
like, getting people to
follow me on Snapchat.
And it hurts my feelings that
I'm not doing a good enough
job that he can't see that.
He literally, in one Tweet, called me out,
without using my handle,
but I know what it stands for.
And the next post is a post of me,
of him doing my Snapchat
step one, step two, step
the thing I created.
That's tactical.
And so it's got me in a bad mood.
Because I care.
I never will take for granted one,
like I hate when people are like,
"Who cares? It's one."
I care.
Can you get me my next meeting?
Hey, guys.
How are you?
Things are really good.
Excited to get on the phone.
I'm excited to share a
couple things on my mind.
Like, I'm personally very
excited about the narrative
of creating the way to do this right.
And I think there's a lot,
in the same way that Oreo
gets disproportionate
for that one Tweet six years later,
I think when this works,
if you guys feel comfortable with it,
I think I can single-handedly
put this on the map
for you guys and us.
And I'm excited about that.
I just want to make sure
we're aligned on that.
Here's my theory and
here's what I want to do,
I basically want this (muted) campaign
to be the campaign of the year.
I want to invent Facebook advertising.
It's hard. I would've never
eaten popcorn anywhere else.
- Other than home.
- Home is bad.
(laughs)
Home is bad.
- Because you're not busy,
you're not doing things.
- I'm in a different mindset.
I need more fruit and vegetables.
It's really simple.
I will call you during this
meeting and put you on speaker,
you'll get a shout out,
but you minimally have to buy
40 books on Amazon right now,
because I'm busy here.
And you've got to send in the receipt.
It needs to be the receipt
that you just bought 40 books
and put your phone number in it.
I'll call your ass on speaker.
You'll get your shout out, we'll jam.
Nope, this is only live.
But I hope you're enjoying episode 15.
Somebody just did it?
- [India] I think someone just
did it, but it's on PayPal.
- Is it Kara or Cara? We'll find out.
(phone rings)
- [Kara] Hello?
- Hello. This is Kara?
- [Kara] Yes!
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Kara] I totally know!
- Thank you so much for.
- [Kara] Oh, my God.
Now I can't see you live
because I just had to pick up my phone.
Now I've got to get you on
live in my computer here.
Hang on.
- Okay, get on the computer live.
So, what are you gonna
do with the 50 bucks?
- [Kara] Oh, I give them out to my agents.
So, I've built this huge
social media following,
and what I do is I do
marketing for a title company.
So, my favorite episode
of The #AskGaryVee Show
is episode 95 because an agent called in
and asked what you would
do if you were an agent.
And so you said, "I
would take the ten miles
"around my office, and I'd
go get all the stories.
And I would write about those stories.
And I teach this in my class all the time.
I swear I am single-handedly responsible
for giving you at least 200
more followers."
- I love you. Thank you
so much. I'm so so happy.
Done. And thank you so much
for buying the book right now.
It's means a lot to me.
- [Kara] You're welcome.
Thanks for calling.
- Okay. Have a great night.
- [Kara] Hi India, hi everybody!
- Oh, India! Bye.
You got another one?
This is fun there's phone calls.
- [Eddie] Hey pal!
- Eddie.
- [Eddie] It's me. It's
not your dad. It's me.
- I know, I said Eddie not dad.
- [Eddie] Hi, you know I did it
just like your dad from the day.
- I remember, how are you, brother?
We got more?
- [India] 40 bucks for a
call, let's get into the call.
- [Gary] You have three more?
This is like derailed our...
It's like derailed our meeting.
Who's this?
- [Male] Michael.
- Michael.
- [Michael] How you doing?
- I'm doing super well, mate. How are you?
- [Michael] Very well, Gary
Vaynerchuk. Very well.
- Nicholas!
- [Nicholas] What's up, Gary?
- Things are good, man. How are you?
- [Nicholas] Pretty good,
man. It's pretty cool.
I just watched you on Facebook,
and I saw the calls,
figured I should take it.
- Yes, that was a good decision, Nick.
This is so fun.
So, you know, some days are just this.
They're a grind.
You're just in it day in and day out,
hour after hour, minute
after minute in the meetings.
And it's not glamorous,
it's not getting the accolades
of selfies and being there.
It's not the big time meetings
with the biggest companies in the world
or the titans of industry.
It's just hardcore dirt, right?
You know, just grinding the
operations, having meetings.
Meeting with people about their careers.
Dealing with issues,
integration, running a company.
You know I hear a lot of people say,
"Oh, it's speaking and
the books and stuff."
This is my day to day.
My day to day 70% of the time
is just hardcore dirt work.
You know, getting your hands dirty,
putting in the work, having the meetings.
Doing what an executive does.
Which is architect,
orchestrate, things that scale.
And so, I enjoy today.
As much as I enjoy going to LinkedIn,
or as much as I enjoy hanging out with a
$5 billionaire worth sports owner
and thinking about my future,
and thinking about the
accolades and the attention
and all that.
I get equal, if not
slightly more value out of
putting in the actual
work that has allowed me
the attempt for the audacious goals
that I've created for myself.
Cool.